what we got here is a UAV which we use
for the Afridi reconstruction it's an
octocopter and has a still image camera
on it and here you can see the controls
with a live view we're using this system
for 3d reconstruction so we are flying
up there taking images and from this
images we do something that's called
structure promotion and basically make a
3d reconstruction out of them
promotion is basically you find some
salient points in the images and then
find them in more images from different
positions and with this information you
can basically see where the images were
taken and also extract the 3d structure
out of that this is a bit when people
use I mean it's related to stitching
because or they're also you find the
correspondences but you really get the
3d structure which is very different for
stitching you don't want to move your
camera for 3d reconstruction you have to
move the camera that's why it's called
structure from motion instead of having
two cameras like a stereo rig you move
one camera from one to the other place
and to other places and use this
information to extract the 3d and then
these images are streamed down to the
computer where the intelligence resides
basically so you take these images to
this structure from motion get in rough
idea what the structure looks like from
there on the system can decide whether
or not the user requirements are
fulfilled and if they're not filled it
will decide where do I have to take more
images so that it actually get what the
user wants a complete 3d reconstruction
with a certain resolution a certain
uncertainty and this is then done
automatically so it plans where it
should go then you can launch the a
maybe it flies to those positions takes
these images and updated 3d
reconstruction with that information
then it can improve itself and make a
new plan and decide whether or not it's
fulfilled now it's semi autonomous I
mean you have this planning strategy
which basically tells you where you and
it flies around but you can intercept at
any point in the pipeline before you
launch the launch there may be during
the execution there's always you always
have to control with you and can
intercept at any point they're all the
only thing you have to also do tell the
system is what is interesting in the
scene the system itself does not know
that this here is a scene where this
represents some of the vegetation rounds
the rock you want to reconstruct it's
taken an image
and then judging from the image where
the vegetation is basically here these
markers are just used for to your
reference not for the reconstruction
itself and you take images of this here
and then we also learned how these
different structures have to be treated
differently because the rock is smooth
and kind of easy to reconstruct well
this high-frequency structures you could
call it the vegetation is really hard to
reconstruct for that you have to treat
it differently and our program basically
learned how to treat it differently and
uses that to improve the 3d
reconstruction already in the
acquisition on-site during the flight
over here we have already taken some
pictures of the scene this point you can
see here and then also where actually
the pictures were taken from and with
that information it knows ok over here
for example there are some regions which
are not nicely covered and then implant
some views that actually these parts are
covered this work normally you can then
just click start and then it would go
around and move and take these images
for you you always have to take care
that it sees all the objects for example
there might be kind of power lines or in
small structures they might not see
itself so if you see it plans in there
you of course helps to change the plan
for them so it's not like totally
autonomous we wouldn't do that so
there's always a human supervising it
and saying but it's really hard if you
just have this plan here and want to
execute it without the automation it's
really really hard it takes a lot of
experience and even then you won't be
able to get exactly the position but for
the system it's very easy and it just
helps you to get where you want it to
help it the hardware is basically
off-the-shelf but all the software was
developed in in-house basically so the
whole component with the 3d
reconstruction the planning and the
execution then is always then sent back
to the new weave so we're basically here
dealing with the intelligence of the
system not the hardware sorry we're
working in
- with partly open-source partly
software that was developed in source
and is commercial and then we give
programming language is mainly C++ but
we also have CUDA for accelerating it on
the graphics card you can see a
reconstruction on the top is basically
with our algorithm which learns to treat
different kinds of structures
differently and here in the bottom is
what happens if you don't used it
your reconstruction becomes very sparse
only the really smooth surfaces like
this rock here survive the vegetation is
basically missing everywhere but with
our software you can see even here
underneath this trees here which are
included if you just fly about it it's
well reconstructed here because the
system decided all right over there
there's our overhang I have to take
pictures to actually get that in there
it doesn't know that it's really
vegetation it just knows the structure
that is in the image is hard to
reconstruct and I have to treat it
definitely this has actually no semantic
meaning in it so it doesn't know
vegetation as a word or anything you
just knows that it has to treat it
differently
this software is kind of generic so you
just train it in whatever task you want
and also for like reconstruct
construction sites you can use it and
then evaluate how the construction site
changed over time well what a thing you
can change just for ancient buildings so
basically the purpose is reconstruction
whatever you want to reconstruct you
could do this as long as it's some kind
of static object we'd like to thank
audible.com for this episode of computer
file and if you visit audible.com slash
computer file as a chance to sign up for
a 30 day free trial
they've got over a hundred and eighty
thousand books to choose from and having
made this video about scanning rock I
went searching for a book on rock and
came across lots of books on rock music
now this called to mind one of my
favorite books
ESPA dare Street by Ian banks it's kind
of dark shows how one band making it
their success turns slightly to tragedy
so check out s pedestrian sign up for
your free trial at audible.com slash
computerphile thanks once again to them
for sponsoring this video
but subtracting these frames from each
other we can virtually shroud the
influence of daylight so we can even
eliminate cast shadows which would
because